[Music]
from jennifer lopez and marc anthony's
look-alike little ones to Neil Patrick
Harris and David Burtka cuties et's
running down our fave celebrity twin
kids that have stolen our hearts it's
fun I'm not gonna lie first up mariah
carey and nick cannon six-year-old twins
monroe and moroccan hanging out in the
studio chillin with their famous celeb
friends backstage and cuddling up to mom
on a yacht JLo is definitely a great
mama to her precious little ones Max and
Emme these two live a luxe life with
their pop star mom and singer father
Marc Anthony who's cool enough to let
his eight-year-old daughter his nails
pink I felt very very lucky we aren't
always lucky enough to see Angelina
Jolie and Brad Pitt eight-year-old twins
Vivienne and Knox but when we do they're
adorable as ever give them a little bit
of a wing Neil Patrick Harris and hubby
David Burtka skids Gideon and Harper
often makes special appearances on their
pops social media page baking swimming
and just being too stinking cute and we
can't forget about supernatural star
Jensen Ackles and wife Daniel Harris's
twins son Zeppelin and daughter arrow
these two are already captivating our
hearts and they're just four months old
here they are being bottle-fed by their
famous dad making hilarious dramatic
faces they sure were born ready for
Hollywood
[Music]
you